Thank you for coming to this symposium.
I'm Yosuke Togashi from Okayama University, Japan.
Sorry, I have a little jet lag, so please deal with me
kindly.
I
first introduce this symposium,
focusing on mitochondria transfer
disclosure.
So
Warburg effect,
traditional theory concept in
cancer metabolism.
Cancer cells were thought to rely on glycolysis,
because
mitochondria
were damaged or broken.
This is traditional Warburg effect.
However, modern understanding
is different from Warburg effect a little.
Not damaged or broken,
but
reprogrammed
to enhance glycolysis, while
also cancer cells use mitochondria OXPHOS
in a context-dependent manner.
This is modern understanding
about mitochondrial cancer metabolism.
Of course, mitochondria produce ATP through OXPHOS
mitochondrial respiration. However,
mitochondria not only
produce ATP,
but also have various functions
in cancer cells.
For example,
biogenesis and turnover
dynamics,
evasion of cell death,
oxidative stress control,
of course, signal transduction, and metabolic reprogramming.
So,
to understand such mitochondria, we have to
remember evolutionary history.
Based on endosymbiotic theory, mitochondria
once
were free-living bacteria, which enter into
early eukaryotic cells and became organelle.
A single cell contain more than hundreds of
mitochondria with own genome, mitochondrial DNA.
So based on such theory,
mitochondria can
move from cell to cell. This is mitochondria
transfer research field.
Considering the bacterial nature,
I can accept this theory. How about
audience? Maybe accept, because you
come to this symposium, I think, I believe.
So,
please accept this theory.
First report,
20 years ago
pronounce,
but a little experimental
artificial model.
However, recently, there are several reports about mitochondria
transfer related to various disease,
including, of course,
our main focus, cancer,
as you can see here, cancer.
For example,
cancer cells steal mitochondria
from surrounding immune cell or
fibroblast or such environmental cell
to increase their proliferation,
or impair antitumor immunity. There are several
such reports.
So in this symposium, I have invited
a distinguished speaker who
published an exciting paper recently.
First speaker, Simon,
will show very sophisticated mitochondria
transfer tracing system,
as well as transfer from
NAB to cancer cell.
And second,
my
team also published in "Nature,"
focusing on tumor-derived mitochondria transfer
to immune surrounding cell.
And third speaker, Luca,
will show potential for therapeutic application
using mitochondria transfer. So we are moving
traditional Warburg effect into
new concept of mitochondria
network, metabolic network.
So by understanding
this concept, we
can develop a new novel therapy in the
future.
Please enjoy this symposium.
So first speaker, Simon from South Alabama University.
Please start.
Hello, everyone. Thank you. Thank you, and thank you, Yosuke, for the
invitation today. I'm very pleased and honored to
present our recent development in the lab.
Right now, we are located at the University of South Alabama, but
my research group is about to move to Oklahoma University in
June, so stay tuned.
So this is my
disclosure statement.
So in the lab, we are studying cancer aggressivity and in particular
cancer metastasis, because
actually cancer metastasis is the first reason of
cancer mortality.
When cancer are not metastasized, they are
most often easily removable through surgery, but when they start to
spread throughout the organism,
there is no way for the surgery to fully eradicate the
cancer. So that is why there is such intense research
development about cancer metastasis.
And one main reason about metastasis is the cancer cells'
plasticity and most importantly, its dynamics.
And you can see in these pictures of in vitro 41
triple-negative breast cancer cells.
You can see the acquisition of two different type of populations.
One, a population of epithelial cells that do express
E-cadherin. These cells as the cells that are
required for the cancer proliferation, but also for the seeding at
distant site.
For instance, E-cadherin allows the cells to attach to each other.
That's important for the primary tumor.
That's also important for the cell seeding distantly, as the cells need to
reattach. So on the early stage and the late stage of
cancer, it's known that cancers must harbor such
an epithelial phenotype.
But on the same time, the cells are transitioning through different states,
including the mesenchymal state, where cells are drastically changing
their phenotype. And as you can see here, we start to express mesenchymal
markers such as here the vimentin marker in green.
So vimentin is a cytoskeleton molecule, and it allows the cancer cells
to basically migrate and invade their surrounding environment.
This is important for the cells to leave the primary tumor and escape
and progress through
the metastatic cascade.
However,
when the cell state is mesenchymal, they are vulnerable at some state of cancer
progression. For instance, they will not do very well when they are
circulatory tumor cells, and circulatory tumor cells does perform
better as a cluster of cells. It's well known.
And cluster of cells will engage epithelial molecules for the cells
to attach together.
So altogether, what we try is to understand the mechanism of this
plasticity to block the cancer cell plasticity, thinking we can block
metastasis. And we have tried in the lab to isolate these red cells
versus green cells by single-cell isolation.
But at the end, we keep regenerating cancer cells
cultures from this isogenic population that are a mix of
red and green. So which mean if we had a video of that pictures,
you will see cells changing from red to green to red to--
constantly changing between these two states, and we fail to stabilize these 10
lines into a mesenchymal or epithelial type phenotype.
However, in another model, which is an immortalized non-cancer model,
which is the normal murine mammary gland cells, MMUMG,
we saw at the very first passage from the ATCC
that most of the cells are more like an epithelial phenotype, but some
cells are more like a fibroblast-type phenotype.
And we were able to isolate by single-cell seeding to generate two
isogenic population. The epithelial phenotype was easy to
obtain, as they represent 99.9% of the original
cell population. And we were able to isolate some clones of the cells
harboring this mesenchymal phenotype and having clones that are
stable on this state, that are locked on the
mesenchymal states. So we used
this model, and basically we did
transcriptional analysis. And when I did the gene ontology analysis
for the genes that are differentially expressed between the mesenchymal and
the epithelial phenotype on this isogenic model, so which means the
cells have the same genetic background.
So I had to scratch my head looking at the gene ontology because
what came out was related to axon
guidance molecules and memory loss and this type of biological
process. And here we are talking about breast cancer cells in a Petri dish,
not even on an animal. There is no neurons on the area.
So I had to figure out what was going on with these mesenchymal cells
expressing axon guidance molecules, neurons-related molecules.
And actually, if you have a suspicion that your cells
could modify the nervous system or
interact with neurons,
the simple assay you can do is the axonogenesis assay in vitro.
Basically, you take the supernatant of your cells
of interest, and you stimulate neuronal precursors,
such as PC12 cells here with this supernatant.
And as you can see, when I take the epithelial cell supernatant, there
is not much reaction of the PC12 neuronal precursors.
But when I subject these cells to the supernatant of
mesenchymal cells, they start to differentiate and form more
mature neural type of cells, which is actually because these
mesenchymal cells express axon guidance molecules, which trigger the
differentiation of these neuronal precursors.
And in our specific case here, we were identifying
the Semaphorin 4F as a major driver of this phenotype.
And if you block Semaphorin 4F expression in the cancer cells,
then the supernatants will not trigger this differentiation of
neuronal precursors anymore. So it brought my research interest to the
field of cancer neuroinvasion, and I started to think, wait, is there any neurons
in cancer? At that time, it was not so obvious.
So, and actually, if you get a xenograft of triple-negative breast
cancer cells, you can see indeed here in green labeling the
tubulin beta III has a pen neuronal marker.
We can see the existence of nerve bundles here and nerve tweaks.
Actually, nerve bundles are preexisting nerves that are invaded by cancer
cells through the process of perineural invasion.The nerve twigs,
that's an interesting aspect, is the generation of new nerves that are infiltrating
throughout the tumor.
And actually, the fact cancers can be innervated is not a new concept.
It has been established in 1887, from my knowledge, the
first demonstration of the presence of nerves into tumors by Dr. Young.
And more recently, in 2001, Dr. Gustavo Hajela published
this very seminal paper when he was the first to mix
neuronal precursor cells, like neuronal cells
from the dorsal root ganglia with prostate cancer cells.
And what he saw is there is a directional
communication between the
neurons and the cancer cells, showing there is a nerve cancer and crosstalk which
is occurring. And since then, the field of cancer
innervation has been constantly growing, as you can see here
on the PubMed entry related to the field.
However, I want to put this in parallel with the field of cancer
angiogenesis. And as you can see, cancer angiogenesis is in red, and we see the
development after the Folkman demonstration and Folkman
theory about angiogenesis. You can see in green, we still have a lot
of room to grow in the field of cancer neuroscience, and that's very
exciting. So please join the field if you have any idea in that direction.
So what we have learned so far is there is a strong correlation between
cancer innervation and the clinical outcome.
More innervated cancer, higher nerve
density, is usually associated to poor prognosis, especially to
more metastasis. And in preclinical model, mostly
mouse and rat, there is a clear association between nerve density and
aggressive behaviors. Generally, when you denervate tumor,
you have a less aggressive cancer, especially related to metastasis, but also
to tumor growth. And more generally, the contribution of
the nervous system on cancer behaviors is still a complex
phenomenon.
For instance, parasympathetic nerves can have different effect in different
type of cancer.
It's still something which is ongoing, and we are trying to elucidate.
That's very exciting.
So to go back to the research we are doing in the lab, so to recapitulate,
what we demonstrate is the aggressive breast cancer cells, the mesenchymal
type, that are activated for the epithelial-mesenchymal transition.
We are secreting axon guidance molecules, such as the Semaforin 4F.
And you can see this triggers a differentiation of neurons and a filtration where
they come and extend axon and neurite and come in contact with cancer
cells, as you can see here. The neurons is in green, and the cancer
cells here are labeled, like the nuclei are labeled with DAPI.
And you can see the existence of point of contact that suggests
communication between neurons and cancer cells.
And we wanted to validate this concept more on the in vivo setup,
thinking that maybe we know that cancer plasticity is associated to
metastasis. However, there is a big debate about how cancer metastasis
is linked to this plasticity process.
Our idea is maybe cancer plasticity can trigger cancer
neurogenesis, and this neurogenesis could have something to do with the increased
metastasis because clinical data show more nerve density is
associated to more metastasis. So simple approach here, we blocked
the
plasticity of cancers in vivo by
basically suppressing the TGF-beta signaling using a dominant negative
strategy, overexpressing the receptor two of the TGF-beta
receptor into the cells. And as you can see, we
mostly block the TGF-beta signaling on these cells.
And when these cells are injected as a xenograft, what we found is tumor
weight was
very similar, nothing very spectacular in term of change of tumor
size. However, there is a drastic decrease on metastasis.
And actually, that's not our finding.
This was known in the literature, and that's why we use this model.
What we wanted to do is to check if this decrease of
metastasis is also associated to the decrease of cancer innervation and
cancer nerve density. And so we looked on the tumor samples, and
we found that indeed, when you block the cancer plasticity, you also
block the attrition and the development of nerves into the
primary tumor.
So overall,
we move to this idea that maybe the cancer innervation is
one of the many link between cancer
plasticity and cancer metastasis, that simply through
triggering axon guidance molecules, the cancer plasticity
triggers nerve infiltration and therefore push the
tumor into a more metastatic phenotype.
However, so far, correlation is not causality.
So we moved forward and tried to get the biology and get
the overall influence of the nervous system in breast
cancer. So for that, we use the 4T1 triple-negative breast cancer
xenograft model. And actually, first, we denervated
the mammary fat pad of the animals using Botox that block every
nerves. And then we injected the primary
tumor cells and let the tumor grow.
And these cells were expressing a fluorophore, and we were able to isolate them
by flow cytometry. And basically, we compared
the non-denervated versus
denervated tumor to check at the change at the transcriptional level.
And long story short, what we found was striking.
We found decrease of many biological process, but they were all
related to metabolism and mostly related to mitochondrial
metabolism. So we had no choice to go to that direction because
that was the only-- it's where we're showing.
Basically, when you remove nerves in cancer,
the cancer cell's metabolism is decreasing, and it's mostly
associated to mitochondria metabolism
decrease.
So to get a more simple pictures, we moved back to in
vitro system, where we wanted to test if the...
nerve,
like the cancer dependencies on nerves was directly related to the nerve
cancer interface itself, and there was no other elements, as the tumor is
very complex and a lot of other
cells could have been implied. So we developed a neuronal stem
cells, two cancer cells co-cultures that I do not have the
time to develop today. But basically, as you can see here, the
neuronal stem cells
expressing the GFP fluorophore, when they are mixed with cancer cells
expressing the mCherry fluorophore, they come, they are attracted by these cancer
cells because they secrete axon guidance molecules.
And they come in contact, and what was striking is this contact are sustained
over the time. It's not a touch and go.
It's not just the neurons are sensing what is going on.
When they come in contact with cancer cells, they sustain this
contact at the nerve cancer interface.
So we thought that's interesting, and this was showing that there is
indeed a crosstalk between these cells.
And we tested if what we found in vivo was true in vitro.
So basically, we isolated these cancer cells, which were
cultivated alone, here in blue, or cultivated in the presence
of neurons. We isolated them by FACS and tested their
mitochondrial metabolism. And what we found, we confirmed that when you
add neurons to the cultures, when cancer cells are exposed to neurons, they
do increase their
respiration capacities. They
increase their
mitochondrial metabolism,
which could be somewhat surprising because now the cells are competing with each
other. On the same dish, we have to share glucose and oxygens,
but we would have expected some compensation mechanism, but actually, we see the
opposite. These neurons boost the metabolism of
cancer cells. And actually, that's great because that's confirming what we found in
vivo with the Botox experiment. So we moved
forward, and I cannot go through all the process we
went, but we ended to the conclusion that maybe this boost in metabolism
could be linked to the direct transfer of mitochondria between cells,
especially because neurons have very abundant and
very good quality mitochondria. Mitochondria
in neurons are among the best on the organism.
And so as you can see here, we can do genetic labeling on the mitochondria with a
green fluorophore. Here, that's the neurons, and the cancer cells expressing
mCherry fluorophore receive some mitochondria.
You can see these three globular mitochondria into the recipient cells, as
observed by confocal microscopy.
So this was documenting the transfer at the nerve cancer interface, and we
wanted to see, before moving forward, if it was a true reality
in human samples. So we took these samples, and that's a
collaboration with Dr. Gustavo Ayala.
We took these samples about perineural invasion occurring, which is very frequent
in prostate cancer. And you can see here, the nerves is located in
brown and around are the cancer cells that are wrapping around the nerves.
And what we did label is the mitochondria into these cancer cells, and by
using AI-based segmentation as well as multispectral
imaging, we quantify the quantity of mitochondria per cell on
the patient samples. And what we found is
the closest the cancer cells are to the nerves, the highest is
their mitochondrial content. So it does clearly show the
mitochondrial dependencies between nerves and cancer cells in patient
samples. Still, it doesn't show the transfer, but it's suggesting it.
So we moved forward and with Dr. Ayala, he
performed a clinical trial on human prostate
patient samples where patients were injecting
Botox on one side of the prostate when the other side was
injected with saline. So each patient was his own control.
And we looked at the mitochondrial load into cancer cells in both the
Botox-denervated versus the saline-treated
side of the prostate
cancer. And what we found is when you denervate the
cancer in human, you indeed see a decrease on the mitochondrial
content on the cancer cells on the denervated side of the
tumor.
So to demonstrate the transfer in vivo, we had to move to a murine model,
and basically, we took advantage of a mutation on the mitochondrial
DNA, which is located for the 41 cell lines.
Actually, this cell line is isogenic for the balb c mice, but those
are more like a C mutation. And we used that, developed a
quick nanopore sequencing pipeline, and basically, we
injected the cancer cells into the animals.
And after the tumor onset, we isolated the cancer cells and checked
for the presence of non-mutated mitochondrial DNA into the
cancer cells, which is showing actually the transfer of mitochondria from
the mouse to the cancer itself. And as you can see, we
got 10 to 15% of cells that were positive for non-mutated
mitochondrial DNA, which is coming from the host.
And to test the influence of the nervous system and the contribution of the
nervous system on this process,
we actually made the same experiment with denervated tumor,
and we did see a significant decrease on the transfer between the mouse to the
tumor by 35%. So some may argue that
35% is not a majority, but think about the quantity of neurons in
a cancer like that. There is only 1 to 3%
neurons in cancer. And here we show that 1% of neurons into the
tumor stroma can contribute up to 35% of the transfer of
mitochondria. So that's actually a huge contribution.
And a reason for that is likely neurons are very long, and they are reaching out
many cells. One neuron's going to reach hundreds of cells.
So that may explain why there is such a prevalent transfer
arising from the neurons.So we thought
it's interesting and wanted to move forward to better understand
what the biology behind it. And the problem with the strategy I was
presenting to you earlier is with labeling the GFP with
mitochondria, you
cannot permanently mark recipient cells, and therefore you cannot follow the
fate of the cells receiving mitochondria from any donor
cells. And you cannot distinguish cells that never receive
mitochondria versus those that receive mitochondria.
In the sense that when the transfer occurs, the GFP signal will
quickly disappear on the recipient cells.
So that's a good way to document the transfer and to quantify the transfer at a
given time, but not a good way for lineage tracing.
So we designed MitoTracer basically in the donor cells.
So this can work in any type of cells. We use that for neuron cancer transfer.
And basically on the neuronal cells here, we overexpress a Cre
recombinase, which is anchored to the mitochondria outer membrane,
and this is separated by a TEV protease cleavage site.
And on the recipient cells, we do have a classical mCherry to
GFP Cre-Lox switch. So basically, the cells are constitutively
expressing mCherry 304 until they are
subjected to the Cre recombinase, and this Cre recombinase removes the mCherry
and put the GFP in frame, and the cells are
turning into permanently green cells.
And one trick here is mitochondria never go to the nucleus.
So the trick was to express the TEV protease by the recipient cells.
So once the mitochondria come and are transferred to the recipient
cells, the Cre is released by the TEV protease, and then
it's going to the nucleus because there is an NLS on it, and you can activate the
switch. And this is the type of video we can have on the time-lapse
microscopy. You can see these red cancer cells.
They are constitutively red, and when they are
receiving mitochondria from the donor cells that are non-labeled, they turn
into a green color, which is permanent. So that the MitoTracer technology.
And basically, we can use this technology to backtrace the transfer.
And here you can see the cells that are making these transitions that
receive a neuronal mitochondrion.
Those after they have established long tunneling nanotubes, between
neurons and cancer cells, we actually demonstrated most of the transfer are
occurring through that route.
So together we use this strategy to understand the impact of the transfer
of mitochondria into the cancer cell biology and especially
metastasis. So basically, we took the nerve cancer co-cultures,
injected into the mice, and as you can see here on the
primary tumor, we observe 5 to 6% of cells having receiving
mitochondria
from the neurons. But when you looked on the metastatic
sites, here is the lungs and the brain, we do see a strong
enrichment to these green recipient cells, which does demonstrate that
actually that these green cells that receive mitochondria into the primary tumor,
they are more likely to perform metastasis and to succeed
in forming distance metastasis.
So basically, we try to understand a little bit about the mechanism beyond that,
behind this increase in metastasis.
A little disappointing when we isolated the red versus green cells,
tested their invasive capacities in vitro in a Boyden chamber, and we did
not see a difference in invasion on the cells.
So I had to scratch my head again, but actually, we went back to the mice.
We injected the red versus green, and we confirmed that, yes, the green cells are
more metastatic. They are not invasive per se, but they are more metastatic.
And actually, the metastatic process is a very complex
multi-step cascade and is also very inefficient.
So ultimately, 99.9% of metastatic cells
will fail to form distance metastasis. There is many reason for that.
For instance, oxidative stress and shear stress, which is obtained on the
bloodstream, are main reason for metastatic cells to not
survive. And actually, we tested the red versus green
recipient cells for these metastatic stressors.
And we confirmed that indeed, the green cells are more
resisting to oxidative stress and are less dying when we
give them physiological quantity of oxidative stress.
And the same is true, we developed with this shear stress
assay where we pass these cells through fine capillaries, about 10
passages, and this tends to kill the cells because of the shear stress.
And we see that in term of dying cells, the green cells,
the recipient cells, are performing much better, so they can resist better to the
shear stress.
And so this will explain why we see more metastasis
after the transfer of mitochondria into the cells.
It's not invasive per se, and actually, it's bringing us to rethink
the rates of metastasis and think how metastasis will occur and what
we should target. Because for a long time, and still we
keep trying to find the genes and the
mechanism that produce invasive capacities in the cells.
But as we can see, invasion metastasis is not only about
invasion, and actually, there is 0.1% of the population
that needs to be targeted. Every metastatic cell is invasive, but
not every invasive cell is metastatic.
And actually, we need to think more about metastatic cells
being very well organized and networking cells.
And when we can target this network or target this subset of cells
that are efficient to survive during the process, we may make significant
progress toward blocking metastasis and
enhancing patient survival.
So overall, I want to thank my outstanding research team
and as well my collaborator, especially Dr.
Gustavo Haian, which have been working with me on
this project. It has been an absolute pleasure to develop it.
And thank you for your attention.
Thank you presentation. Is there any question, comment from audience,
please?
Great talk and really fascinating field.
I was just wondering,
have you checked-- you showed that 35% of
mitochondria are being transferred from neurons.
So have you checked whether other cells in the tumor microenvironment,
like fibroblasts or macrophages, they also contribute
too?
Yes. I think that's going to be discussed today during this session.
But actually, we tried
several types of cells, and every cell is transferring
mitochondria. What we found is, in general, neurons
are better donor in mitochondria in our system.
And there is two reason, is neurons
are designed to reach out and deliver, so they are
good at giving mitochondria. And another reason is neurons have a lot of
mitochondria to give. They are very abundant in term of mitochondria.
But in general, there is no cell lines, no cells
we tested that did not give any mitochondria.
And we think that's more like a global physiological mechanism, which is
hijacked by the cancer cells. And
the natures of mitochondria into the neurons makes them very
attractive in boosting metabolic plasticity on the
recipient cancer cells.
I have one more follow-up question.
So
I was just wondering whether this metastatic phenotype which you are
seeing, is it because of any mitochondria transfer,
or they are getting some particular kind of mitochondria from
neuron, which is helping them
to live under this oxidative and shear stress?
That's a good question. Actually, I will let Yusuke and Luca
develop that later. But yes,
the origin of mitochondria matter, and it can actually be
good or bad. It depends on what mitochondria you receive or what
mitochondria you give.
Thank you.
Please, Mark.
Very cool stuff. Did you happen to take a look
at those human samples where you saw an increased correlation of the
mitochondrial,
and see if those cells also have an increased
epithelial-mesenchymal transition as well?
If they become more EMT-like.
That's a good question. And that's also the chicken or the egg question.
Actually,
I will tell you, we don't know yet. We explored that a
little bit, but we didn't go very fully on it.
The question is, what we found is mesenchymal cells are more
likely to transfer mitochondria or receive mitochondria.
And the reason is they are more likely to establish contact with other cells.
And actually, in the nerve cancer interface, they are also
secreting this axon guidance molecule, which make this crosstalk even more
developed. So
it's likely associated. We didn't go on full
details, but yes. Technically, yes.
Thank you.
Frank.
So is it bidirectional or
unidirectional when the neurons are
donating mitochondria or the tumor cells are
hijacking
in vivo versus in vitro cell culture? Do you see any difference?
So we did not test the bidirectionality on the nerve cancer
interface, but I know other peoples have shown the transfer of mitochondria in
the other direction, and I think they are in the room today, so I will give them
the opportunity to develop that
during this session.
Final question.
Fantastic work. I have a question.
Did you characterize these mitochondria that are
transferred in term of phenotype?
It may be difficult, but do they change when
they change from nerve cells to cancer cells?
That's actually what keeps us up at night, and we are
studying that in detail right now.
We have been fortunate to be funded by the NIH to try to respond to that particular
question. So I cannot respond to that question yet, but that's very
interesting topic that we are exploring further right now.
Thank you, Simon.
We are going to next speaker, Maitan.
Again, Maitan Yosuke Togashi from Okayama University.
Today, my talk focus on tumor-derived mitochondrial
transfer to immune cells, so opposite
transfer
from previous talk.
Our disclosure.
So my laboratory mainly focus on cancer immunology and
immunotherapy. And as you know, cancer
immunotherapy has made
a huge progress, a revolution in
cancer treatment.
A part of patients can achieve durable
response similar to cure. However,
such patient remains limited, less than
20%.
We should
struggle, attack insufficient efficacy,
in some cases, hyperprogression.
We want more patient
achieve durable response.
So I started cancer immunology research
10 years ago.
I first searched for
specific T-cells that directly attack cancer cells,
tumor-specific T-cell.
We found a
PD-1 positive exhausted T-cell in TIRS
exhibit tumor-specific reactivity.So
I was interested in exhausted T cell,
chronic antigen stimulation induced T cell
exhaustion. There are various feature in
exhausted T cell, for example, high expression,
inhibitory
checkpoint molecule,
epigenetic change, and
mitochondrial dysfunction, metabolic dysfunction.
So I'm interested in mitochondrial
dysfunction in exhausted T cell, metabolic dysfunction
in exhausted T cell.
To elucidate the metabolic state,
I performed unconventional analysis at
first, because I was also interested in mitochondrial
transfer.
That is, I sequenced
two
cancer cell and peripheral blood from the same patient.
The result are very striking, very lucky.
40% of human T cells have
mitochondrial DNA mutation,
many of which shared with cancer cell.
Maybe transfer, I think.
However,
I have a concern about potential contamination.
This is
our procedure to establish a TIL from human clinical
sample,
tumor tissue digest, and
expand using IL-2. Maybe
our TIL consist of
T cell.
However, we have some concerns, so we checked
our TIL using flow cytometry,
scatter plot, FSSS,
lymphocyte,
singlet, live/dead, and live cell, and
we confirm our TIL mostly consist of
CD45 positive, CDC positive, double positive T cell.
Again, we sort this population and we validate
mutation.
Sorted TIL actually had same mutation,
and we also sequenced for FFP sample, and
we confirmed the same mutation. So
we concluded our identified mutations
were not contamination, were not acquired
mutation, maybe transfer.
Seeing is believing. We performed a mitochondrial
transfer experiment. We stained the TIL
with MitoTracker Green, a little
tricky staining
color, but it's difficult to stain primary T cell
using other staining color, so we
use MitoTracker Green for TIL.
However, we stained the cancer cell with
Mito-DSRed, a reporter specific protein,
and co-culture for two or three days.
And as you can see here, DSR positive TIL
were found after two or three days.
So mitochondrial transfer actually occur in our
experiment.
We also validate mitochondrial transfer using in vivo
experiment. Not so sophisticated model
like SHIMON.
Conventional system, we transduce
MitoDSRed
into cancer cell. This cancer cell have this
mutation.
And subcutaneous transplant, and we analyze
TIL day 21 to day 42.
Lymphocyte, singlet, and live
T cell fraction here, and
we checked the DSR positivity in this
fraction. As you can see here, DSR positive TIL,
especially T cell, gradually increased.
And we sort DSRed negative population and the
DSRed positive population and
sequenced by single cell level. All negative
population
had wild type mitochondrial DNA. However,
positive population had mutation,
heteroplasmy and homoplasmy. So we validate
mitochondrial transfer in this mouse model.
What mechanism of mitochondrial transfer?
There are several report
about mitochondrial transfer mechanism.
We created various condition, and please look
at these bars.
In these bars, we use
insertion column, separate column,
inhibit cell-cell contact.
Separation column clearly reduce
mitochondrial transfer. And we also used
this inhibitor, tunnel nanotube inhibitor.
And this inhibitor also reduce mitochondrial transfer.
So direct contact via tunnel nanotube
play important role in mitochondrial transfer.
And please look at this bar. This bar we use
EV inhibitor, especially small EV exosome, and
EV inhibitor reduced mitochondrial transfer.
So indirect communication via
EV also important for mitochondrial
transfer.However, I have one
question.
Just one or two mutated mitochondrial
transfer
to T cell
might not affect T cell function, maybe
heteroplasmic
condition.
However,
our identified mutation,
most
frequency very high, more than 80% mutation.
And in a mouse model, a part of two have
homoplasmic mutation. So
I wonder why homoplasmic replacement occur.
So today time is limited, so I skip detailed data
and I summarize in this figure.
We focus on mitophagy sensitivity.
In
several cancer cell,
mitochondria is resistant
to mitophagy.
But in T cell, mitochondria are
sensitive to mitophagy. And we focus
on one molecule, USP30. This molecule is
mitophagy inhibitory molecule, which attached with
mitochondria, especially in cancer cell.
This molecule is highly expressed in cancer cell.
So such
dysfunctional mutated mitochondria with USP30
co-transfer to T cell.
And in the tumor microenvironment, oxidative stress
is abundant, so such ROS induce
mitophagy
against endogenous normal
mitochondria.
However, such mitochondria with USP30 is
resistant to mitophagy. Eventually,
dysfunctional mutated mitochondria
remain, and mitochondria hijack
can occur from this model.
However, USP30 explain
partially this phenomenon. We are now
searching for other factors
comprehensively. So we next
evaluated function, mitochondria DNA mutated T
cell function.
Generally,
OXPHOS in mitochondria play important roles
in memory T cell formation.
First, we
evaluated metabolic state,
using T cell line.
Please look at
these shadowed bars. These shadowed bars
indicate mitochondria DNA mutated JAKAT T cell
line. And
not shadowed white bar mean wild type
in JAKAT cell line.
And OXPHOS was impaired with
increased dependency on glycolysis
in mutated JAKAT cell line.
We also evaluated T cell function, memory formation, and
activation molecule.
Please look at
shadowed and red color bars.
Shadow mean mutated
cancer cell co-culture too, and red mean
DS Red positive transfer recipient too.
So please look at red shadowed bar.
As you can see here, memory formation
was impaired after
mitochondria mutated transfer. And activation molecule
also decreased after mutated
transfer.
We also created these mice
with T cell specific
mitochondria dysfunction mice model.
And using these mice, we evaluated
PD-1 blockade efficacy. As you can see
here, please look at red line, control knockout mice.
Sensitive model, but in control knockout
mice,
MC38 became resistant to PD-1
blockade.
We also conducted re-challenge
model.
After
initial PD-1 blockade,
several mice completely rejected tumor, and
we collected such
mice. And
one month or two months later, we
re-challenged parental tumor.
As you can see here, control all tumor were rejected.
However, in control knockout mice, many
tumor grew, so memory formation
was impaired in this model.
Finally, we sequenced the clinical specimen,
melanoma or non-small cell lung cancer, who
receive ICI.
Please look at red line, mutated patient.
Mitochondria DNA mutated patient have
poor prognosis by ICI.So we
concluded mitochondrial DNA mutated dysfunctional
mitochondria transfer impair T cell function
in the tumor microenvironment,
leading to suppress antitumor immunity
and durable response.
Sorry, I continue.
I move to next
talk. So
there are several reports about transfer
from cancer cell to surrounding microenvironmental
cells.
In this report,
cancer cell transfer to
fibroblast.
We also
evaluated
other
immune cells similarly.
Previous talk,
I mentioned
mitoDSRred transduced cancer cell
models. We created such model, and we
sequenced CD45 positive immune
cells in TIRS
in the tumor microenvironment, and DSRred negative
population and DSRred positive population.
Orange population was dominant in
DSRred positive transfer recipient immune cell.
Orange
population was myeloid cell, macrophage and
monocyte population.
We validate the macrophage transfer
using flow cytometry.
Two weeks later,
mitochondrial transfer clearly increased
to macrophage.
We also validated using confocal
imaging. Red is
DSRred positive tumor-derived mitochondria.
And blue is CD45.
This is a macrophage, and DSRred
positive can be detected in macrophage.
We also sequenced in mice model and
human clinical sample.
Mutated cancer cell and wild type, but this
cancer cell have SNP.
So
there's negative wild type. DSRred positive macrophage has
the same mutation and the same SNP.
We also fresh
living tumor tissue
digest and sort,
and this population tumor cell and this
population myeloid cell, and we sort
these populations and sequence the mitochondria
DNA.
And these mitochondria DNA mutations
was shared
between tumor cells and myeloid cells.
We evaluated
mechanism of
mitochondrial transfer to macrophage.
Different from T cell, we found
tunnel nanotube
was the main
route
in mitochondria transfer to macrophage.
This is confocal imaging data.
These are cancer cell, and this
is macrophage. And this thin tube
is
tunnel nanotube, and red mean
tumor-derived mitochondria, DSRred positive mitochondria, as
you can see here, within TNT mitochondria.
We extracted macrophage monocyte
population and recluster
into four
sub-cluster. And this cluster,
undifferentiated monocyte cluster and mature
cluster. Green are a little
immature,
and mature and tissue resident-like
matured macrophage here.
And after mitochondria
transfer, macrophage
clearly
matured.
Please look at this positive population.
Mature population clearly increased after
transfer.
And
we blockade mitochondria transfer to macrophage
using MIRO1 knockdown model.
MIRO1
famous molecule
to
distribute mitochondria
within cell.
And the MIRO1 knockdown reduced mitochondria transfer,
and maturation of macrophage also
impaired after MIRO1 knockdown.
And we also focus on
mutation
transfer.
Mutation transfer expand this green population,
a little immature macrophage population.
Pro-angiogenic macrophage with high
expression of HIF1 and VEGF.
We confirmed HIF1 and VEGF highly
expressed in mutation transfer
macrophage.So,
in this mutation model, we
use
anti-angiogenic reagent and
VEGF inhibitor suppress tumor growth
and suppress lung metastasis.
In contrast, the wild-type tumor,
this effect was not observed in wild-type tumor.
And we also created conditional knockout mice,
lysosome QUR, VEGF flox,
and we observed similar trends.
Finally, we are now
analyzing clinical sample
from patients treated with anti-angiogenic
reagents. And very small number of
patient data, but presence of mitochondrial DNA
mutation is associated with
good prognosis in VEGF inhibitor.
This is mitoX summary.
Mutant mitochondrial transfer
to T cell
impair T cell function, leading to resistant to
ICI.
In addition to T cell, tumor-derived mitochondria
also transfer to macrophage.
Macrophage transfer promote
maturation,
but mutant transfer expand pro-angiogenic,
relatively immature macrophage subset,
and
which sensitized to anti-angiogenic
therapy. So tumor-derived mitochondria transfer
as a determinant of immune cell fate, linking of
organelle genetics to therapeutic vulnerabilities.
I appreciate all my lab member and collaborator, especially
first part, Dr. Ikeda, and the second part,
macrophage part, Dr. Ohmae, and the clinical
department, and sequence
teams. Thank you for your attention.
Is there any question, comment from audience, please? Please.
Very interesting talk. My question is regarding
the second part of your presentation.
So macrophages, especially mature macrophages, are phagocytic cells
as well. So I guess the question is, how do you differentiate between
active transfer mechanism versus macrophages just engulfing
cancer cells and thereby the mitochondria within the cancer cell?
Phagocytosis?
Yes.
We also conducted phagocytosis experiment,
using FITC-labeled phagocytosis
beads, and co-culture with
mitoDSRED cancer cell and the phagocytosis beads.
And
DSRED positive and FITC positive, double positive
macrophage mean
mitochondrial uptake and phagocytosis macrophage, right?
And we sort such double positive macrophage and
monoculture.
And
within two days or three days,
FITC beads disappear,
phagocytosis.
However, DSRED mitochondrial uptake
remain, more than 70% remain.
30% reduce. So maybe 30% of
DSRED positive uptake indicate
phagocytosis. However, more than
70% mitochondrial transfer, I think.
I think we have data.
In addition to such data, we also check
lysosome staining with
using confocal data. And not
distribution different from
tumor-derived mitochondria and
lysosome staining.
Thank you very much.
Please.
That's very nice talk. Thank you. I have two questions.
The first one, at your early stage when you would start your research, you say
10 years ago, did you look at mitochondrial DNA itself, the
mutation, if there is any mutation mitochondrial DNA?
Our identified mutation?
Various mutation, not hotspot mutation.
We evaluate function,
two or three mutation, and
our evaluated mitochondrial DNA mutation,
loss of function mutation.
But not hotspot, and we could not
evaluate all function.
Okay. Thank you.
Because there are many, many mutations.
All right. The other question is, what do you think is the trigger for the
mitochondrial transfer
in the cells?
There are several report about trigger.
For example, hypoxia, oxidative stress or
TNF,
and
maybe some cytochemotherapy or radiation also
can
trigger.
All right.
But we do not evaluate such trigger.
So did you make the observation that mitochondria also
transfer from the TILs or macrophages to the tumor cells?
Opposite site.
Right.
There are several reports about opposite site steal, cancer cell
steal
mitochondria from macrophage and T cell.
Maybe occur, but we did not evaluate
their-We
not specifically evaluate it, but
we had mitochondrial
reporter mouse, from mouse reporter mouse and
transplant
tumor, and
six weeks later,
10% tumor cell have positive
mitochondria from surrounding cell.
But we did not evaluate it
specifically.
Thank you.
So we are going to move.
Last speaker,
Luca from Germany.
Thank you very much, Yasuke, for the invitation to this wonderful
symposium.
So we have
heard so far that
tumor cells can harness mitochondrial transfer
to propagate and metastasize with Simone or
to disable the immune system. So in my talk,
I will show you how we can use and leverage this
physiological mechanism of transfer to
supercharge T cell for more effective
anti-tumor therapies.
And my conflict of interest.
So,
as we heard from Yasuke,
T cells, once they enter the tumor microenvironment,
they experience mitochondrial loss and
impairment in function. And this is as a result of the
metabolic stress that the T cell face in the tumor
microenvironment. Hypoxic condition, metabolic waste
accumulation, and nutrient deprivation can induce
mitochondrial dysfunction and depolarization, as well as
the loss of mitochondrial mass. And ultimately, these
changes in mitochondrial function can drive
T cell exhaustion by promoting epigenetic reprogramming and
the acquisition of an exhaustion phenotype characterized by
lack of proliferative capacity, reduced
effector function, and higher expression of inhibitory
receptor.
In addition to this
metabolic
and nutrient-derived mechanism,
emerging data,
we heard just from Yasuke, showing that
tumor cells can also donate dysfunctional
mitochondria
to the
tumor-infiltrating cells, as well other work from Shiradita
Sengupta,
where
they actively show that
can be also stolen by tumor cells from T cells.
And this cause
an increase
dysfunction and loss of mitochondria over time, impairing
their anti-tumor function.
So we were wondering whether we could use a similar mechanism of
transfer and
fight cancer cells like fighting fire with fire,
and supercharge our T cells for adoptive T cell therapy.
So what we initially did, we co-culture
both human and mouse T cells with bone
marrow stromal-derived
mesenchymal
stromal cells. We chose this
cell type because in the literature, bone marrow mesenchymal
stromal cells were frequently described as a
very good
cell population capable of donate mitochondria.
And then we perform a field emission electron microscopy and
show that
indeed from T cells and BMC, we can
see the formation of connection through tunnelin nanotubes,
both in human and mouse setting. And if we
look around the tunnelin nanotube and zoom in here, for
example, here in C1, we can see that along the nanotube,
we have an enlargement of the tube
and
potentially underline the passage of organelle structure
within the tunnelin nanotube. And
generally, we could retrieve
one connection from T cells to bone marrow stroma cells.
The mouse pair had
shorter and narrower nanotubes, while the human
cells were
more widely distributed across the sizes in length and
width.
Using the mito-dsRed strategy described
previously by Yasuke,
we showed that if we label a mitochondrial in bone
marrow stroma cells, can indeed be found along the
nanotube connecting bone marrow stroma cell with the T cells.
And inside this enlargement, we have the accumulation of the sRed.
Interestingly, if we
hypersaturate the area
along the nanotube with the
DAPI staining, we could appreciate also the presence of
DAPI staining
in this pocket of mitochondria, indicating the passage
potentially of also mitochondrial DNA
together with the organelle.
To
improve the transfer rate,
my postdoc, Jeremy BaldwinAnd come up with this idea
of culturing the two cell types within a
transwell system.
In a way that the bone marrow stromal cells plated the
bottom of the transwell were preferentially bathed in their own media,
and the T cells lying on top of the bone marrow
mesenchymal stromal cells were preferentially bathed in T cell medium.
And this improved the overall viability of the co-culture
and the transfer rate.
We were
observing a transfer rate about of 10%,
and we could sort easily the cells that receive
mitochondrial DS Red from the one that did not receive.
So
on, we will call the
cell that did not receive mitochondria, mito-negative cells, and mito-positive
cells, the cells that receive mitochondria.
We
quantify the mitochondrial DNA
in mito-positive cells and compare relatively to the mito-negative
cells. We could see that mito-positive cells
contain about 30% more of
mitochondrial content
than
the control cells.
We confirm the
transfer of mitochondria also here by confocal
microscopy, showing that the
internalized mitochondria were functional.
If we stain
the mito-positive cells with a mitochondrial dye,
that's called Mito Deep Red, that is
efficiently stained in polarized mitochondria, we could
see that the transfer cells were functional and polarized.
We could also observe some endogenous
mitochondria only stained by Mito Deep Red.
We also confirmed the transfer
through genetic means, and we took advantage of a snip
present in BALB/c
mouse mitochondrial DNA that abrogate the
Hsp70 restriction site. So in this co-culture system,
we use CD8 coming from a BALB/c animal,
so they don't have the Hsp70 restriction site, so we
can only generate
one band of mitochondrial DNA at 385.
The donor cells
contain the restriction site so they can generate a two band at 274
and 111.
And we confirm in the mito-negative, there was only
the original mitochondrial DNA with only one band.
But in the mito-positive, we could see the endogenous mitochondrial DNA, but as
well the two band coming from
the
C57 black 6 mitochondrial DNA.
And by CLARITY microscopy also, we confirm
that the mito DS Red indeed stain
and colocalize with mitochondrial
structure within the CD8 T cells.
So having demonstrated that mitochondria can be efficiently
transferred from bone marrow stromal cells to
T cells, we wanted to now understand what were the functional
consequences of the mitochondrial transfer.
Could we indeed improve metabolism of the T cells?
And
to do this in a more,
how you say,
cautious way let's say,
we needed a strong control of our assay because you
could imagine that
other molecule could also traffic between one cell to another when these
tunnel and nanotube are formed. And so we
generated donor cells in which mitochondria
were made dysfunctional by
treatment with low doses of etidium bromide.
So these bone marrow stroma cells, ETBR, so treated with etidium bromide,
mitochondria can be stained nicely with mito DS Red.
But as you can see, the staining with Mito Deep Red for
polarized mitochondria is completely
impaired compared to control. And indeed, this etidium
bromide treated bone marrow stroma cells have a less mitochondrial DNA
content. And when tested in a SEARS
assay, they have a really impaired oxygen consumption
rate and mitochondrial respiration.
So we use all this control
in our system, and we can see that the
mito-positive cells, so the cells that acquire functional
mitochondria, have higher basal mitochondrial respiration
as well as spare respiratory capacity compared to the
mito-negative, but as well to CD8 that were not co-cultured with bone
marrow stroma cells. More importantly, when also we compare
with the cell that received dysfunctional mitochondria from the etidium
bromide-treated bone marrow stroma cells, we also see an advantage
in mitochondrial respiration
from our mito-positive cells,
indicating that the transfer of functional
mitochondria was responsible indeed for the
metabolic changes observed in recipient CD8 T cells.
So we then adoptively transfer these
cells. We use a
B16 melanoma model
treated with
Pmel-1 TCR T cells. These cells recognize
GP100 on melanoma cells.
We can see that both group of Pmel cells can induce a nice
tumor regression of B16. However, the cells that did not
acquire exogenous mitochondria from bone marrow stroma cells start
to-relapse and
experience regrowth three weeks after transfer.
While the mito positive cells induce a much more prolonged
anti-tumor control and prolong the survival of the animal.
This better anti-tumor outcome were associated with
a better engraftment of mito positive cells compared to
mito negative cells. We could retrieve a higher
frequency of cells in the mito positive group in the
spleen, but more importantly, at the tumor site also, we
retrieve in the tumor,
more transfer cells that could be marked by
LY5.1 congenic marker,
compared to the mito negative group.
Another important observation that we did was that not
only we have more
T cells in the B16 melanoma, but also in the mito positive group,
these LY5.1 Pima cells were able to
infiltrate more deeply into the tumor bed,
compared to the mito negative cells, which remain confined
at the edge of the B16 tumor.
We wanted to understand also if
these
exogenous mitochondria could confer, improve, and
sustain
metabolic capacity of the transfer cells.
We perform
a flow cytometry-based assay called SENIT that use
puromycin staining as a surrogate marker of
metabolic capacity, because the majority of the
ATP produced by cells is devoted to the generation of
new protein and translation. And we could see that,
especially at the tumor site, the mito positive
group
show an increase in
total metabolic capacity compared to the mito negative
group. So indicating even seven days after transfer,
the
mito positive cells maintain a metabolic
advantage compared to the
mito negative group.
We also wanted to understand whether these metabolic
changes could result in a different
trajectory and a differentiation
path of our transfer cells. We
isolated
Pima cells seven days after transfer from the tumor, and
we generate a UMAP. We can found
here four different
cluster. So the mito negative group
were more enriched in cluster three, while
mito positive cells were found mostly in cluster
zero, one, and two.
So when we map
this
single-cell RNA-seq into a mouse TIL atlas that
comprise over 16,000 single-cell transcriptome
from B16 melanoma and MCA38
adenocarcinoma, what we found that is the cluster three is
essentially comprised exclusively by exhausted cells,
either precursor or terminal exhausted.
Whereas in the other area, in the mito positive cells, we had a
large amount of cells that
were proliferating effector or functional effector
memory cells, even though there were still some cells that
experience also exhaustion in this setting.
We were excited by this finding in mice, and we wanted to understand
whether we could translate also this technology in the human
setting.
We first test
CD19 CAR as a platform model. We
show initially that
mito positive cells, CD19 CAR positive cells, could
kill better Nalm6 leukemia in vivo.
This enhanced killing was dependent on mitochondria, and
the mito positive
cells that receive mitochondria from etidium bromide
treatable marrow stroma cells
could not show this increase in the
cytolytic activity.
And also by performing a sequential round of
tumor challenge, we could see that the mito positive cells
could eliminate all cancer cells up to
around six of
restimulation. Whereas in the mito negative group,
starting from around three of restimulation, some donors start to
experience dysfunction, and by around six, all the three different
donor in mito negative group were unable to kill
efficiently Nalm6 leukemia.
And this is translated also in a better anti-tumor function
of our mito positive cells in a Nalm6
NSG model of
leukemia with better tumor control and prolonged
survival.
We wanted then to test also if this could potentially be
a method to improve TIL therapy.
If we
co-culture bone marrow stroma cells with a TIL, we could also
observe about 10% of transfer
rate
in this setting. And by testing in
vitro
the activity of TILs that are mito positive versus mito negative
against
melanoma cells, we could see using both immortalized bone marrow
stroma cells or primary derived bone marrow stroma cells,
better
anti-tumor killing in the mito positive
group.So the
data, I think, are a very nice proof of concept for
translational purposes. So what is limiting is the 10%
of transfer rate that we observe in our system.
We wanted to improve the transfer rate, and we
start learning what are the
molecules that are involved and important for mitochondrial transfer in the system.
So by comparing the human and mouse cells that
uptake
mitochondria versus the cells that did not uptake mitochondria,
two molecules came up as strongly upregulated
in the mito-positive
group.
They were talin-2 and lopacsin.
These two molecules are involved in focal adhesion and membrane
protrusion. So we thought they were interesting.
We focus initially
in addressing the role of talin-2.
We use CRISPR-Cas to knock it out talin-2 on
both end, either in CD8 or bone marrow stroma or in
both
component of the co-culture.
We could see that talin-2 was critical for the transfer
in CD8 cells, but more importantly in the bone marrow stromal
component. And if we use
both pair deficient in talin-2, we could further on
impair the transfer. Was not abrogating the transfer, indicating that
potentially other mechanism, and we didn't explore
what Yusuke did with the extracellular vesicle.
There might be also involvement of extracellular vesicle
responsible for this remaining 40% of transfer.
In summary, we think that this strategy can be
seen as an air fueling, where we have the bone marrow
stromal cells that are an air tanker that can
fuel efficiently
the CD8 fighter jet so that they can go and
fight cancer more efficiently. And with that, I
would like to thanks all the people involved in the study,
particularly Jeremy Baldwin in my lab.
That was the main driver of the study.
Sridatta Sengupta
for the field emission
electron microscopy images. Mattia
Iannaccone, Donat Inverso for the CLEM, and Kilian Schober for the assistant with
the SENI study. And with that, I'm happy to answer any question
if you have.
Please.
Back, please.
Great talk. Jonathan Brestoff
group has shown that if you give directly isolated mitochondria
to macrophages, they take up and they are
functional. Because you mentioned that mitochondria transfer is
limiting for you. So I was just wondering whether, have you treated directly with
isolated mitochondria and seen if...
So,
we try to use also
isolated mitochondria,
and try to see whether we could transplant this isolated mitochondria
into T cells.
In our end, we observe very limited amount
of transfer in T cells.
We try methods like the
mito,
what was it? The nomoto punch. The
one with the
centrifugation, but we didn't see much
transfer. So the other problem when we are thinking
about transferring isolated mitochondria is that
when you isolate mitochondria, you expose the
mitochondria to potential damaging
buffers. And there are some work also
showing that the
long-term maintenance of the transfer mitochondria, if they are
transplanted, is less
efficient than the mitochondria that are transferred naturally
through endogenous mechanism through the tunnelin nanotube.
Thank you.
Mark.
Thank you for the beautiful presentation.
Thank you.
I understand the
mechanism and everything, but
while on the TL makes completely sense
because the TL have been stressed in the context of the tumor, and we
know all that, what happened to the mitochondria in that condition.
Can you please explain why in normal T
cells-
There is a touch.
That should be
healthy, right?
Yeah.
When you put them in contact with mesenchymal stromal cell
transfer of the mitochondria.
Mm-hmm.
Which is the difference between the mitochondria in the mesenchymal stem cell in a
wall type T cell? What is the difference?
Why they should work better?
So,
we need to
transfer mitochondria to T cells
in activation state. So if we have T cells
that are just simply co-incubated with bone marrow stroma cells,
we don't see any transferring happening.
So the cells need to be activated, and
then
we can see that a fraction, 10%, can
acquire mitochondria.
If we look at the genetic signature of cells that
acquire mitochondrias in this setting, we saw that
the
cells that acquire mitochondria tend to have a signature of
oxidative stress,
similar to what is seen in TLS. So if
we
do gene set enrichment analysis, for example from
an... fields that have
shown
you can distinguish cells that acquire
mitochondria from this genetic signature.
And
we see that
this same signature also is enriched in our
mito-positive cells in vitro. I think just the activation
of T cells create some sort of oxidative stress that
can promote the acquisition of mitochondria.
The mitochondria got acquired after the stress, right?
Yeah. So you need to activate them.
So this creates a cellular stress activation,
and this can
enable the cell that are more stressed to acquire mitochondria.
So if they are the mitochondria from bone marrow stromal cells and
one from an healthy CD8 T cell different, we don't know.
So we think that the advantage is not done in this setting,
maybe by the quality of mitochondria, but the quantity,
so we have much more mitochondria.
Indeed, we see an increase in mitochondrial mass that is
also maintained
for at least one month after transfer.
The mito-positive cells maintain higher mitochondrial mass than the mito-negative.
But it's an important question, and we would like to address if the mito type are
also important and different.
Thank you.
Nice presentation. I just have a quick question about the benefit of mitochondria
transfer that you showed. Have you compared it to other
approaches of inducing mitochondria, for example, like
driving mitochondria biogenesis, PGC1 alpha, and
other works that have been done?
No, we didn't compare directly. We think
that
this strategy
could have a particular advantage when you're talking about TIL
therapy more than CAR therapy. So with CAR therapy,
you have
potentially healthy cells if they are from donor, but from
patient, maybe there are also some cells that have some mitochondrial
that is damaged from all the chemotherapy and prior therapy.
But in TIL, it's particularly obvious because also of the
stress and the dysfunction caused by the tumor microenvironment.
And
so when you're talking about mitochondrial biogenesis,
any way to improve mitochondrial function, you need to rely on
functional mitochondria. If you already have dysfunctional mitochondria,
this maneuver are potentially less effective.
And that's why we think that in healthy mitochondria from a donor or
cells that have not been stressed
could potentially be in a better approach.
Thank you.
Juan.
A couple of quick questions.
I'm sure you've addressed this as a control already,
but do you have a bone marrow stromal cell control
alone to make sure it's not contributing to any antitumor
effect? And number two,
do you visualize the mitochondrial transfer to occur even
after irradiating a bone marrow stromal cell
feeder layer type system?
Okay. So the first question, we don't transfer bone marrow
stromal cells because we
isolate
CD8 T cells with a flow cytometer
sorter. It's highly pure mito-positive, mito-negative
population. They are all CD8 cells, and they are tracking viable.
So the therapeutic benefit definitely
comes from CD8 T cells. We have also,
I didn't show here, but in an additional experiment, we also
use CD8 T cells that were not cultured at all with
bone marrow stromal cells, and they perform similarly to the
mito-negative cells. So the cells that did not acquire
mitochondria.
The other question,
we did not irradiate the bone marrow stromal cells.
What we did, we use
very low doses of ethidium bromide.
At a very low dose, the ethidium bromide accumulates preferentially in
mitochondrial DNA and not in the nuclear DNA, so you can cause
mutation and render the mitochondrial dysfunction.
Yeah. Just to follow up real quick.
But from the product development perspective,
using the bone marrow stromal cell as a feeder layer
for CD8, so we will need to irradiate it.
Do you visualize this working in that setting?
I'm not sure if you will need to
irradiate it. You can
easily enrich the T cells
with magnetic beads, for example, capturing
CD3, or if you want to do CD8 or CD4, you can also target
this molecule easily, and
you can have a product that's highly purified.
The
bone marrow stromal cells are also widely used in the
clinic as a way now to modulate
inflammation. So I don't think that the
extra transfer of some bone marrow stromal cell could
be detrimental, especially if you
create an autologous co-culture system.
If you want to rely on a line, maybe they are more problematic, and
you would need to show that you are able to isolate
the T cells with high efficiency.
Thank you so much.
Final question.
Hi. Good talk. I am interested in terms
of the tumor sites. It's wonderful that you're
supercharging the T cells to have a better response in
killing. I saw in the B16 models till around
day 42, there was a regrowth in terms of the cancer
cell. How does this therapy potentially looks in terms of
long-term, since T cells also have the tendency to donate to
the cancer cell?
That could affect the plasticity of the cancer cell to adapt
and respond better.
So
when you look at the therapeutic efficacy in experimental model,
you always have to think about
that these model
are done in a way that you create a therapeutic window in
the treatment.
For example, with Pima cells, if you transfer 10
million T cells, you can cure all animal for two years
with no problem. So here we are stressing the system.
We are transferring a limited amount of T cells in order to find
a therapeutic window to show superiority of one group to another.
So I'm not much worried about some
relapse at 40 days because if you just
transfer a little bit higher amount of T cells, you could avoid
this
regrowth and have a long-term cure.
The
other question about the potential
transfer back to the cancer of the transfer
mitochondria in our T cells.
So we look into this question
with a limited amount of experiments.
So what we did, essentially, we took advantage of our Mito DS Red
to track if there was an uptake of Mito
DS Red. But some of the transfer cells also lose the DS
Red with time at seven days. So for what we saw, we
didn't observe any uptake of
Mito DS Red from our transfer cells to the B16
tumor.
And we think that this is the case because
when we are
transferring a T cell product that is highly active and
supercharged by this extra mitochondria, once you get in
contact with tumor cells, it just kill them.
So it doesn't give the possibility to the T
cells to steal or to interact by
donating dysfunctional mitochondria. So any interaction result in the killing.
If you have probably a cell that is less active, then you can have
this immune escape mechanism taking place.
Thank you.
Thank you, Luca. We are going to close this
symposium. Through this symposium, I hope
everybody accept this phenomenon and this research area
expand
reading to clinical applications.
Thank you for your cooperation.
Thank you